[Music]
in serial-killer news Oh No submitted by
me no like me not kill cereal yeah baby
you beat it up not eat it up cereal mmm
you eat it up eat the cereal like I eat
four loops I was sad because I love
cereal growing up you bet and you
thought the more shaking the [ __ ]
honey bunches of oats I think we're just
getting rid of these cereals and I'm
like why that's the love cereal me to a
u.s. Border Patrol agent confessed to
murdering four women and abducting he
like he rapes and kills I'm not sure if
raping was involved in any of these but
I do know that the majority of the
victims were sex workers sounds like it
sounds like yeah talk about abuse of
power yeah hookers jump at the border
and stuff so this takes place in Loretto
Texas and in that city there's an area
where it's predominantly like drugs and
sex trafficking and that's where he was
picking these women thanks for clearing
that up because when you said Border
Patrol I was wondering if it was people
that get sand on their boots or sea
water on their boots bonanno's uniform
when I heard prostitute I just thought
like really hot seductive mexican girls
climbing the fence in their bikini it
was a border town so it's like just on
this side of Texas like TJ I mean like I
just see like a tunnel and then like a
bunch of hot mexican girls super hot
just running to Mexican weather girls
yes and I was like damn I'm not the type
of girls that are prostitutes at the
border those girls are on TV not at the
border you don't know if they have two
jobs this dude he was a border patrol
agent for last ten years and like the
span of just a few days he killed or
women is this next to El Paso you know
still on the geography dude good lunch
Oh Paso is like way for cuz we were
doing a road trip and every time we went
near to El Paso do you want to imagine
it yeah what I got scared because I
didn't have any type of preconceived
feelings about El Paso but then Jessica
and her friends and everybody just so
scared of El Paso
like why I'm from LA
is that right above was it called Juarez
ha no what is this in Mexico yeah but
you know that's where a lot of the
cartel goes through it's called the
Juarez cartel let's just look at a math
later
this all happened between September 3rd
that's that good idea this is 93
September 3rd through the 15th
oh my give me much better report this I
don't know why that's funny that's true
I will look at the map Island that [ __ ]
go we're gonna [ __ ] GPS oh my lord
POTUS ok no this is sad guy so it was
three women and one transgender woman
who were murdered the fifth victim she
was kidnapped because this man did not
let her out of his car but then for some
reason he pulled over to get gas and
that's when she was able to escape which
I thought that was weird I'm like if
you're trying to not to let her leave
what would you don't do that but anyway
maybe he was like on empty right now so
a good thing he did that she was able to
get away and that's how they found the
other [ __ ] up yeah because this man knew
all these victims because they the fifth
victim she asked him like about one of
her friends which was the first woman
who murdered that's when he got upset he
pulled out a gun put he put it to her
test and then I don't know what happened
from there but then he went to a gas
station she ran away
he was caught thankfully because she
started running and she was asking for
help everyone knew that he was a Border
Patrol agent too by the way since this
heaven is such a short span of time like
they're not sure if there's a so many
other victims as he was picking up these
women from that particular place maybe
he thought like they wouldn't be missed
or something and then the even crazier
thing about this was that one of the
victims two weeks before her death she
had a premonition that she was gonna get
shot in the head and that she was
telling her mom like hey and her sister
- she was like hey I had a dream this is
how I'm gonna die make sure you take
care of my kids cuz she had two young
kids I'm gonna be dead in less than a
month only two weeks later would be so
sure of it yeah because her mom
you should have never left Mexico land
that's [ __ ] crazy she was already she
was in Laredo well if I have a dream
like that I'm gonna do something to
trick my [ __ ] future and that might
be the reason why you died because you
didn't stick to the original routine oh
[ __ ] she's right this mission you never
know so it's like no matter what my
dreams gonna happen yeah well no no then
I'm gonna just stay in bed and do this
that's probably why it happened she was
able to tell her mom like this this is
how I'm gonna die and then the mom took
a video of her saying that she was like
what the [ __ ] is so weird
did it go viral no well it doesn't be
released as a me release of it
the cops have that video man why don't
you stay alive should have been a great
a switch yeah or not a witch Oracle yeah
yeah like a fortune teller fear a wizard
Harry no no no it's a it's a psychic
it's like a tarot card reader a fortune
teller my interdimensional people they
could communicate I think that's like it
starts with the T traveler no Tony the
Tiger anyway moving on tarantula what a
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] dude I hope he
goes to Helen Ross wait so what was you
don't know he was like picking up these
girls under the assumption of that what
like they're gonna [ __ ] yeah they're
gonna [ __ ] right no oh I don't know what
sparked this but he all of a sudden
hated all sex words all prostitutes he
wanted to eradicate got a [ __ ] st I
know yeah yeah so like how did they know
that he wanted to rid the world of like
sex workers do they have some sort of
manifesto or something like well they're
saying that it was during interviews
that he said that he disliked the sex
trade and that that's one he wanted to
eradicate the prostitutes cuz he has
been he's killing the wrong people he
should be killing the people that are
like like the person yeah into doing
this work
that was stupid seemed like she kept
killing these women because they were
saying like you were the last person who
was with this the last victim or
whatever and then like that
[Music]
oh you kept having to kill other women
cover his tracks cuz he accidentally
killed one prostitute and then he had to
kill another one even for a friend with
the plot thickens the K man it was like
where's my sister at you know to kill
her and shishun
I remember the one I was trying to say
clairvoyant oh that's what I'm trying to
say I just thought what a tape I thought
it was train does not stop my doctor
Angela thought I was trans trans boy you
know there's a lot of serial killers
that do go after prostitutes though why
there was a couple that one woman I
forgot her Eileen
something the one that killed all
monsters that wouldn't be in the movie
monster
oh she pretended to be a girl no she was
a hooker she said that she kept getting
beat and taking advantage and all this
stuff so then one time like she just
turned on her jaw and start killing and
then apparently they're saying that she
just liked killing at that point and
just started killing all these John's as
in like everything every single like
client they're like hater uh she's just
like well I don't know every single long
but she just started killing them her
clients yeah that's one of the reasons
why we should make prostitution illegal
only because to protect the workers
because they're gonna do it anyway yeah
good tack them too right right and then
but the main thing is that they can
actually feel safe calling the police
and saying like this [ __ ] beat
my ass yeah like there's I think there
was a law passed recently where like
online like the sex workers can't post
their like ads or whatever - so it's
like getting pushed more into the
streets but even that law like kept them
from having their little like John
blacklist like website where like they
could say like this guy was dangerous
like don't take calls from it's like a
uber for John's yeah those web sites are
getting wiped out because there's a new
law so they're even more [ __ ] now
maybe the politicians that are in charge
of those laws are the ones that are
doing that shift to the prostitutes and
they don't want to get caught so they're
like [ __ ] this
politician pip luckily you've been
caught now he's in Texas so hope he gets
the [ __ ] gas or whatever injection
you already has to win oh who asked
alpha 2 and it's the old school like
black and white one - looks like these
stripes
oh brother where art thou costume right
that's full of hey guys gonna walk
around with the bowling ball attached -
yeah he's gonna like dig his way out
with a spoon easy Mexican is it Mexican
yeah this girlfriend comes in with a
[ __ ] cake a little nail filer inside
the name is Juan Juan David Ortiz - my
buddy works at the court system and he
was saying like gangs are so
sophisticated in the way that they get
drugs and things into the system and one
of these gang bosses daughters would
come in looking really hot miniskirt
low-cut dress and she would always be
offering like free food to the guys
every time she comes to visit and then
you know he would always refuse it and
say like ah no thanks I don't want it
but one of his other friend like his
co-workers would take it all the time
come to find out that was like a
weigh-in and then like they would have
sexual relationships and all that stuff
and then she would get drugs through the
tacos to the jailer and then he would
give it to like the gang members inside
and then he got caught for that so they
find all these clever ways to bring like
the power the pussy's inside yeah they
use their own family members like stayin
to less
[Music]